[Music]
this is your tech news briefing for
wednesday august 24th i'm zoe thomas for
the wall street journal
twitter is facing new allegations at a
sensitive time for the social media
business
the company's former head of security
peter zatko has filed a whistleblower
complaint with the securities and
exchange commission according to a
representative of whistleblower aid an
organization that helped file the claim
he accuses the company of failing to
protect sensitive user data and of lying
about its security problems
the accusations come just weeks before
twitter is set to face off against elon
musk in court over his attempt to back
out of a deal to buy the company
here to discuss the new allegations and
how they could affect twitter is our
tech reporter sarah needleman hey sarah
thanks for joining me it's great to be
here
so start by telling us a little bit more
about what this whistleblower is
alleging
sure um well there are many allegations
but broadly speaking he's alleging that
the company's been pretty laxed with its
security and privacy processes
but more specifically
the complaint goes into allegations that
the company has been
misrepresenting the number of
monetizable daily users on this platform
and that's the number it uses to
calculate spam
and fake accounts or estimate spam fake
accounts and that's interesting because
that is the main area focus for elon
musk who's in a legal battle with
twitter and he has argued that he should
be able to walk away from his 44 billion
dollar deal for the company because he
believes that it has been dishonest and
is actually committed fraud by not
providing um accurate numbers on that
issue so this complaint appears to sort
of support mr musk's theory so who
exactly is this whistleblower who's
making these allegations
uh this whistleblower was twitter's head
of security but he was uh fired from the
company in january
he has a long resume in the security
area he's worked for the us government
he's also worked for google and
for stripe the payments company
according to his linkedin he's also a
former hacker who is known as mudge and
he's been a noted computer security
researcher for decades
he was a member of a boston cyber
security collective they came to
prominence in 1998 when it offered
warnings about the state of national
cyber security and testimony to the
senate
and during one senate hearing the group
famously told the lawmakers they could
take down the internet in 30 minutes
so he was part of that collective so
that's just the point being that this is
um not just any cyber security
professional this is someone who's been
in the field for decades and is very
well known and he was brought on by jack
dorsey who at the time was still chief
executive of twitter to help it improve
its security and privacy policies
and practices but within about a year he
was fired and a twitter spokeswoman said
that he was fired for
ineffective leadership and poor
performance the spokeswoman also said
that the complaint is riddled with
inconsistencies and inaccuracies and
lacks important context
so we know zadko was hired by former
chief executive and co-founder jack
dorsey but what was his relationship
with the current ceo parag agarwal
what we know from the complaint is that
mr zacco has accused mr agrawal of being
dishonest with the board um he has
accused mr agrawal of pressuring him to
essentially report false or misleading
information to the board
and has agarwal at all responded to
these accusations
well mr agro put out a memo to employees
on tuesday and that was shared on
twitter of course
he said he knows it's frustrating
confusing for employees to read uh this
complaint
which he called inaccurate and he
defended twitter's work on privacy and
security
and he added that the you know attention
that the complaint has brought to the
company is going to make it harder for
them to do their jobs uh mr agwal also
said that the company is going to pursue
all paths to defend its integrity
as a company and set the record straight
so you mentioned that this complaint
appears to support musk's theory on the
number of bots on the platform have we
heard anything from musk or his team on
this
a lawyer for mr musk said that they've
already subpoenaed mr zacco
and that they found his exit from the
company and and that of other employees
curious
in light of what they've been finding
through the discovery process
what do we know about how this complaint
came about in the first place sure he
joined the company in late 2020 and
sometime over the course of 2021 he
started raising concerns
about the company's security and privacy
policies
and essentially he said in the complaint
that those were swept under the rug and
that he was actually discouraged from
bringing the concerns he had to the
board
and so he ultimately was fired in
january and in early march he went ahead
and approached the whistleblower
organization which resulted in the
complaint that was filed in july and
that has become public
so what comes next here what comes next
for the whistleblower and what comes
next for twitter
well for the whistleblower it's going to
be a matter of whether or not the
federal agencies are going to launch an
investigation so the department of
justice for example the sec
they've all been made aware of the
complaint when it was filed and so the
question is whether or not they're going
to
launch investigations into the matter
for twitter again it depends on whether
or not the federal agencies launched an
investigation in which case it would be
expected to
deal with that the company right now is
preparing for its lawsuit
against mr musk there's a five-day trial
scheduled to begin uh in october
that's a non-jury trial and so the
company right now is preparing for that
all right that was our reporter sarah
needleman thanks so much for joining us
sarah my pleasure
and that's it for tech news briefing
today
you know if you enjoy the show why not
tell a friend about it or leave us a
five star rating and a review it helps
others find the show and it lets us know
you like what we're doing i'm zoe thomas
for the wall street journal thanks for
listening
[Music]
you